Hi everyone. Welcome to talks at
Google and it's great to have Sandy,
Jen co founder and Cto of
honor here with us today.
Sandy founded honor in 2014 and prior
to that she was cofounder and Cto of
Meebo,
which is a customer internet company
that focused on connecting publishers and
consumers socially and she led their
engineering team and then join Google
actually,
uh,
in the social team when a Meebo was
acquired in 2012 and before that she also
got her bs from Stanford
University in computer science.
So it's great to have you with
us today, Sandy. Great fear.
I like to get started by having you
tell us about what honor is in your own
words.
Sure. Um, so honor, uh,
our mission basically is to change
the way that our parents age. Um,
I think aging is a topic that a lot
of us don't talk about with people,
especially our own parents. Um, there's
a bit of sort of child fear, um,
when talking about, uh, issues like that.
And so honors goal really is to
remake the way that folks can, uh,
age at home specifically. Um, so we
really focus on nonmedical home care,
which means that we help folks with a,
what we call Adl.
So activities of daily living, things
that you and I take for granted, you know,
brushing your teeth, getting out
of bed. I went to the bathroom. Um,
and we have a whole host of,
um,
really awesome care professionals
that go and do that work.
And what inspired you and
your team to start? Honor?
Uh, good question. Um, so, uh, uh,
three of the four founders are multiterm
entrepreneurs and so we've, um,
we all kind of cut her
teeth on social media. Um,
I've actually had been at
Google for a little bit, um,
and we, uh, once we sort of,
you know,
so all those companies and sort of took
a little time off and we merely wanted
to do another venture and we
really wanted to think about, okay,
well what would make us really
want to work hard, like really,
really hard because the startups
are a lot of work. Um, and, uh,
we ended up sort of thinking
about what's important to us.
And we were a little bit older
or a little bit more chairs,
some of us were having kids. Um,
and we really wanted to have impact.
That was like the biggest thing. And so,
um, when we were kind of getting together,
we kind of thought about, okay, well what,
like what are big problems
that we could solve?
And we thought about unemployment,
poverty, you know, Labor, uh,
child care, health care, elder care. Um,
and then my cofounder from
evo went home one day, um,
to Connecticut to visit
his mother. And she, uh,
he likes to tell the story that she
gets speeding tickets in Montana,
which you just don't get cause cause
there's nobody monitoring center.
The freeways in Montana.
And she was driving really slowly.
And so he started to get a little freaked
out about like, wait a minute. Like,
why are you driving so slowly?
And she was like, well,
it's just getting a little harder. And
so he's like, I live in California,
you live in east coast, you know, when
you're older, what am I going to do? Um,
I know I don't want to pluck
you away from your house.
And so that sort of spurred the idea.
We kind of really started to do some
research in caring for seniors and it's a
really, really big space. Um,
and then we really honed
in on the nonmedical a home
aspect of it because it was
very broken. Um, and when you find him
that's really broken as an entrepreneur,
you kind of get really excited cause
you're like, oh, what can I help?
What can I do to fix this? Um, and so
we kind of started explore that idea.
How do you feel like your experience
working on Meebo in the social space has
influenced your work here with honor?
Um,
so I would say doing a previous or prior
startup to doing honor was definitely a
Prereq to do this type of
venture. Um, honor is complicated.
Like home care aid, you're touching
people directly. Uh, it's a very,
very, uh, hands on experience. Um,
and so in order to solve
such a big mission,
you need to sort of know how
to execute, how to, you know,
gather resources higher,
like a lot of the sort of nuts and bolts
that I learned in my first startup.
And so my experience at Meebo really
sort of taught me generally how to form
organizations, how to run
a team, how to hire. Um,
there are a lot of mistakes
we made in Meebo, which, um,
as an entrepreneur are
selfishly for a second venture.
I want to feel to not make
the same mistakes twice. Um,
so it was a good opportunity to just kind
of take all the learnings that we had,
um, sort of gathered in our previous
experiences and then, you know,
really consolidate all that learning
into a new venture. Um, and so,
so far it's worked out really well.
And how long have you guys been
available to consumers? Actually,
so we started, uh, we're
about three years old,
but we've been giving care for about
two. Um, and so the first year,
obviously a lot of us didn't know much
about home care. Um, like I, you know,
I had some personal experiences
with, with my grandparents, but, um,
really digging into the industry.
It's been around for a really long time.
It hasn't changed much in 30 years,
but there are a lot of
nuances and complications and
considerations in home care
that, uh, without really doing it,
you don't really get exposed to it.
And so the first year for us was a ton
of learning and then we started to take
those learnings and execute on them.
Okay.
Prior to the interview,
I was just reading on this market and
it's actually like a huge business
opportunity in terms of how much money
people spend on home care and here,
but it's something that I don't think
tech has addressed up to this point.
Why do you think that is?
Yeah, so it's, it's interesting
cause people think technology,
they think old people and they're
like, this is just don't mix. Um,
and the way we've thought
about it is, um, you know,
if you think about your grandparents
or your loved ones who are older,
like they use microwaves and
twisters and TVs and cars. Um,
and that's all technology, but it's
not in their face as like technology.
And so you had to sort of rethink about
how you use tech to address needs for
that kind of audience.
And so for us,
I think there's just been that stigma
I think in silicon valley and just
generally in technology and as a
whole that seniors don't do well with
technology. Um, and I think
there's always been these,
I think it's a mistake to
kind of overcater to a senior
audience by having like
giant buttons and like
giant Font and you know,
basically treating them as children,
um,
without really understanding what the
root problem you're trying to solve.
And so we definitely don't think of
ourselves as a technology company like
honors specifically positioned
itself as a services company.
Because at the end of the day,
our product is a person. Um,
and I say this very often that
we are a human services company,
like the person that we send to your
home to help, you know, you do your, uh,
activities of daily living.
That's our product.
And so all the technology that we
build, um, is in service of that.
So a lot of stuff that we build,
the end consumer never sees,
but it's completely built to
deliver the best care possible.
What was the hardest part of the process
as you were starting out with this
company?
Um, I think, uh, as technologists,
you have this sort of,
uh,
want to automate everything and make
everything really efficient. Um,
and so you come in with a blog, a bunch
of assumptions. And so as engineers,
we're like, okay, we're just
going to build this thing.
We're going to build that thing. This is
the way it works. You just go to visit,
you do this, you do that, and then
when you actually start to do it,
we all ended up volunteering in senior
homes to help out and you're like, wow,
that's not, that's not
how it is. Um, and so, uh,
we had to basically learn to strip
away all of our assumptions. Um,
and, uh, in the very beginning, you know,
we had folks who were running care and
delivering care and working with our care,
our care professionals.
Um,
and they were kind of doing one thing
and then the engineers and product team,
we're kind of doing another thing and
we were trying to build things for each
other, but we weren't really in sync
as much as we should have been. Um,
and I think that's a common problem
because you make assumptions,
you work one way,
you make some geo work one way,
but at the end of the day you really
have to work together, like really,
really together to
understand what's going on.
And so once we kind of figured out that
we were not building the right thing, um,
that sort of changed the course
of how we did product development,
which I think is different than what
you'd find in a more traditional software
technology company. Um, we really had
to sort of rethink how we did that.
You mentioned that you went
to visit some senior homes.
What else did you do in terms of use or
research or validating the product and
getting feedback on the product?
Yeah, so we knew we didn't know
anything really. So, um, and uh,
if you think about home care,
it's basically two sided.
You have Washington multi-sided,
you have the person receiving the
care so that the recipient of the care
recipient who could be older or have
different medical conditions, um,
you have usually a family member.
Um,
sometimes not who might be the one
responsible for helping care for the,
the, the senior. Um, and then you have the
person who was actually doing the care.
So the care professional, um, they're
traditionally called caregivers,
but we really wanted to
raise their profile. Um,
and so we there and the work
they do is really difficult.
So we actually called the
care professionals, um,
and then care pros for short to give them
sort of more of the respect that they
actually deserve. Um, and so we
had to basically talk to everybody.
So we, we put herself out of the bay area
cause a barrier is kind of weird. Um,
as you won't know,
it's a little bit of a bubble.
So we went to like different areas,
talk to different care pros, you know,
asking them sort of, you know,
what does it you do, you know,
what's hard in your life? Um, why
do you do this work? Um, you know,
they could, a lot of folks who at this
wage level could literally make more,
you know,
flipping burgers at Mcdonald's,
but they choose to do this work because
they really care. So it's like, like,
why are you making a decision? I'm like,
what are the hardships in your life? Um,
why do you work for this
agency and not that agency? Um,
and so just really being open to
understanding how their thinking.
Um, and then when you start to get
the same answers over and over again,
then you start to think, okay, now
I'm seeing a pattern and trend.
And that can then inform the product
that you build and how you want to create
that interaction.
Hmm.
Your comment about the wages that the
caregivers are earning reminded me that I
saw the CNN article that mentioned
that in 2016 you transitioned from a
contractor model to an employee model.
Is that something that continues to
today and why they choose to do that?
I think in the beginning were like,
all right,
we're just going to kind of try the
contractor model because you know,
that's sort of, it seems to easiest. Um,
and so we started recruiting people and
then it turns out that there are certain
restrictions in a contractor
model that you, uh, for example,
can't train your folks very well.
Um,
there are certain
limitations on the amount of,
um, sort of personal interaction
you can have with them.
And so the one of our core
tenants has always been,
if you could treat the care pro better
and put them in a better place in their
lives, they'll be able to do their
jobs better, right? Because if you're,
if you're like not happy at home
and you're trying to make ends meet,
you're not going to be able to care
for people very well. And so, um,
one of the things that we heard over and
over again from care pros was that they,
you know,
they might get a 25 cents increase in
their hourly wage after staying with an
agency for like three years.
Um, there's no performance,
like based, uh, reward. There's no way
to know that who's a good care of her,
who's a bad care pro.
And so one of the things that we thought
would be really cool and that they,
they sort of were asking for was some
way to develop your career as a care
professional is a caregiver.
Um,
and so the only way you can really do
that though is to give them signals as to
what they're doing really well and what
they're doing not so well what they can
improve on. And then you can train.
And so one of the he reasons we did,
we started to make the switch to an
employee model was that with employees you
can actually train and develop and like
really invest in them as people and like
as workers.
Um,
and so that was one of the primary
reasons we decided to make that change.
And they're still employed today.
So,
so then you mentioned the
valley took care givers.
If we look at this in comparison to
traditional senior care centers or senior
care models, what value do you
add to the other key players?
So then in this case,
the,
maybe the seniors themselves or also
maybe the family members who are,
uh,
buying the care for their senior?
Yeah, so, um, the current
industry is very fragmented. So,
uh, if you think about anything like
over the con and the nationwide,
there's something like 40
to 50,000 agencies. Um,
it's not because like no one's ever
tried to make up a large agency.
It's just really hard.
Um,
you have a bunch of
people on the demand side,
so all of your seniors needing
care and like, you know,
they'll say your grandmother
might have a bad hip and you know,
this chronic medical condition and
she's allergic to dogs and she requires
someone who can lift someone
out of bed every morning.
Or my mother or grandmother might meed
to speak Mandarin and she's allergic to
cats and she, you know,
has three sets of stairs.
So you need somebody who will
lift her downstairs said.
So the requirements for people
are Super Heterogeneous.
And then on the demands
on the supply side,
like care pros are also
very heterogeneous.
Like this person that might
be able to lift 200 pounds,
but this were some may not
this person pieces language.
This person can only drive five miles
outside of her home because she has two
kids that she needs to pick up after work.
Um,
and so there are all these sort
of stipulations on both sides.
And so doing a match is actually
really difficult. And so, uh,
if you are a small mom and pop
agency, which a lot of these, these,
these places are, you don't have
the logistical, operational,
sort of like technology brain to do that
because you're trying to do it on your
head.
So you might have a staff of a few people
trying to like match all these things.
And so, um, a lot of
it is also very analog.
So I care pros, we'll literally have to
take a telephone in the morning and said,
okay, what am I going to go? Um, they'll,
they'll literally take their notes per
visit on like a spiral bound notebook
with the tensile and they'll leave
it on the desk. Um, and so, uh,
we also talked to folks who, you know,
who run agencies with the little,
they drive around to all their clients,
pick up those notebooks, you know,
transcribe some of those notes into
their own system and then return all the
notebooks back. Um, so
it's, it's just very manual.
And so one of the things that we hope to
bring in the hand have been bringing is
a more technology bent on this
world, those, that rote work.
And so one of the key learnings
for us was that like, you know,
you could try to automate everything, but
we're not going to send robots do care.
Like that's just not gonna work.
Um,
and so what we can do is those have
computers do as much as the sort of main,
like the, uh, the rote tasks,
the, um, matching algorithms,
the gps tracking stuff. And then
let the humans do that. Really,
really human stuff. And so we
can get there about, you know,
call 80% and then let
the humans do the rest.
And so one of the things that we've been
trying to do is actually just give more
transparency to the process, right?
So if like I live in California,
but my parents are in the east coast and
I have someone I caregiver going every
day,
um,
I can't go and find that spiral bound
notebook and have someone read that to me
every day. So we have given
an APP, so they care pro,
we've given an to the family,
they can see notes right away,
they can call on any time.
I'm scheduling's a lot easier,
um,
the technology we use to then be able
to track and give you progress notes on
sort of how the visit is
going his way. But, you know,
sort of amazing in this
industry for a lot of folks. Um,
and so just trying to up the quality
and transparency of care itself,
um, has been a huge goal for us. Um,
and definitely the ability
to use technology to scale.
So because we have all this
technology we might have,
we might require one human to do this
instead of 10. And so when you have that,
you can save a lot of those,
um,
that time to go do other interesting
innovative features to help with care
delivery. So definitely a technology
is definitely used to scale to pin,
make better,
better care,
better quality of at the same time we
have to recognize that it can't replace
humans. And so at the end of the day,
the human human experience is still the,
the end product. You mentioned that
you provide training for your care pro.
So what does that training
and compass, it can vary, um,
to sort of like basic skillsets. Like
how do you lift and transfer, uh, uh,
someone who has a, um, who's bedridden
out of bed of bed into a chair.
Um, how do you take someone
from their bed to a toilet? Um,
there are things like, okay, uh,
what is the best way to,
um,
assist someone in this particular task?
Um, and so we can also do things like, Oh,
if you, if this person
has Parkinson's, um,
these are specific tools and techniques
that you can use to help maneuver them
physically. Um, if someone has dementia
here, things here, techniques and sort of,
um, generally accepted ways
to communicate or to, uh,
elicit, uh, feedback
from, from those folks.
And so a lot of it is sort of
a skill wise, but also, um,
how do you basically interact
with different types of people?
Because a lot of our, our, uh, clients,
uh, their conditions vary greatly. So,
uh, it's not like one,
one bucket fits all.
And in terms of the
composition of your audience,
are you looking at mainly people who
are soliciting care for their family
members or actually seniors themselves
who are asking for services for
themselves? Yeah, it's both.
We thought in the very beginning that
we'd have more of what we call adult
children. So it sort of someone, a child
or a nephew or a sort of family member,
then you're responsible for
someone who's older. Um,
but we also have folks who
just want care for themselves.
They recognize that they would want,
well they want to stay at home,
they don't want to go
nursing home or facility.
And so having a little bit additional help
is actually really useful. Um, so yeah,
it really,
it just really varies,
but we definitely have more folks who
are getting care for themselves than we
originally thought.
So that again goes to debunk that myth
that seniors don't really engage with
technology. Right. Cause I need to have
some understanding in order to reach you.
In some ways.
Yeah,
they do have to sort of find us.
But at the same time we don't
require any technology to use honor.
But that was a very conscious point.
So like if you don't want to touch a
computer, you don't want to use an APP,
you don't have to. Oh you
can. Like you can most of our
customers call us. Oh, okay.
Yeah.
So then you're also seeing how maybe you
can leverage old technology using new
technology for the platform,
but for the interface relying on them.
Yeah. And so like those
trends will change as well.
So like our current demographic,
a lot of folks just want to call it.
And also you think about if you're,
you know,
an adult child and let's say your
mom falls, which is very common, uh,
entryway into home care. Um, you cove,
you go from knowing nothing about home
care to someone saying your mom needs
like eight hours of care a day
and you're like, oh my God. Like,
what the Hell is home care?
Um,
and so you need to figure out like
what's going on in your remote in a very
emotional state.
And so when you're a very emotional state,
you're not going to like pick up
your iPhone and be like, okay,
I want care and click, click, click like
you're gonna want to call somebody. Um,
and so we have a dedicated team of people
who answer those calls to make sure
that people can walk the people through
that process. Um, and same time though,
if you, you know, have
gotten care for a while,
you kind of know what home care is and
all you want to do is sort of pressing
buttons, you can do that as well.
So there are different options. Um,
and that'll probably change like,
you know,
I think when our one of our goals is to
make honor, take care of us, what world,
so, uh, obviously when we're older,
the times maybe that no one wants to call
it every once you use an iPhone or an
android phone or whatever.
Um,
so we can kind of see the trends
coming into the industry, um, which is,
uh,
a nice side effect of not working in
some sort of more younger social media
stuff because I don't know what the
next 17 year old wants on her phone,
but I do kind of know what the
next 50 year old once. So, uh,
that's been kind of an interesting change
in terms of scaling.
So I see this in home,
elderly care as being
something that requires a lot
of trust built over time and
something that people really have to
open themselves up to and be comfortable
with. So how, as you're scaling,
do you maintain that sense
of trust and comfort?
Yeah. Um, I think the biggest thing you
can do is also always frame your frame,
your product.
And your team in the right way.
So when I said we don't think
of ourselves as a tech company,
but we think of ourselves as a
services company, like that's the core,
like that's the mission. Um,
and so trust is huge because,
um, unlike, I think a lot
of people are like, oh,
why don't you just do childcare to
unlike childcare where there's usually a
handoff where you're physically present,
you give your child to a babysitter or
nanny, and then at the end of the day,
the nanny returns a child to you.
Um,
that doesn't always happen with senior
care because you generally don't live
with your parents at this age where
you're across country or you're not,
not in the same area. And
so the trust part, um,
you have to, uh, it's kind
of both human and tech.
So on the human side you have
to have a great care pro.
Like if the person coming to your home
is terrible, like obviously the trust is,
goes down the toilet. So being really
good hiring, um, really good care,
you know,
having the right kind of vetting process,
the right kind of training
process and interview process. Um,
the other part is just sort of
supplementing that with technology.
So we have gps turned
on for our here post.
When they use the apps we can tell
what they're there. Right. Um,
that's also to protect the care pro
cause we do have a lot of, some, some uh,
instances where the client's like,
oh no,
the care pro never showed up because
they didn't want to expose something to a
family member. But they were like, well
no, they were there. Um, and so it's a,
it's a dual sided thing where you can't,
if you just come with tech,
it's too robotic, it's too cold.
Um, the baby just come with humans.
There are a lot of, you know, sort of, uh,
non verifiable anecdotal things that
were inefficiencies or deficiencies or he
said she said things and so you can kind
of couple those together and then have
a better package to then improve
on that or that trust. My truck
also related to scaling. So I saw that
you guys are available in California,
New Mexico and Texas right now.
How did you pick which cities to go into
first and then how do you think about a
new city that you want?
Yeah,
yeah. So, um, a fear of ours was
actually just going too fast.
Like you hear all these stories about
other companies who have like really
expanded and they had to retract
and we don't want to do that. Uh,
just because if you retract your service,
this is,
this is the thing that's like life
critical for a lot of people. Um,
and so every new market that we did,
uh, currently was an experiment. So, um,
La was a, you know, like an hour flight
away. So can we do, can we do that? Um,
Dallas, I mean, Texas was okay, it's
a couple hour flight away. Like,
can we do that a different time zone? Um,
you know, for all the engineers are like,
oh, time zone, that's sucks. So we had to
kind of like figured out how to do that.
Um, and then Albuquerque was
a smaller area, like a less
sort of dense urban read,
uh, urban regions. So we're like, okay,
can we handle that? Um, and so, uh,
we definitely wanted to learn and we can
be, the best way to learn is by doing.
And so we really carefully figured out
what markets would give us the best
learnings to then be able to take
our model and scale out. So yes,
eventually we'd love to be nationwide.
Um,
in terms of like the next
market we'll go to again,
we'll probably be a combination of,
you know, are there good partnerships,
what's the demographic look like?
Services level,
what can we learn from that
particular market? Um, you
know, things like that. So,
yeah.
And you were at Google for about a
year in 2012 maybe you could tell us if
there's anything that you learned while
at Google that has helped you with on it.
Um, I learned, I didn't want to
be a Google, but, um, I did, uh,
it was really interesting
because I think from the outside,
Google is this like big, amazing,
monolithic collect technology company. Um,
and so it was very interesting for me
personally to learn how that worked.
Like when you come in, it's like, okay,
well how do they form the organization
is how do they make product?
How to make decisions. Um, you know,
what are the roles that they hire for,
how do they hire?
And so for me,
that was really enlightening
because it gave me a, um,
a different perspective on like how I
did my, how I did my team building. Um,
and so, uh, just being
here like learning, okay,
well this team operates this way and
they set goals this way or they hire this
way or they structure this team this
way in order to, to create these, um,
these incentives to get this goal done.
Um,
that was really useful so that then I
can incorporate that into honor and think
about, okay, well, when I'm building
the team, now how do I want it?
How do I want to do it? Right? I
can, I've learned this from Meebo,
I learned this from Google and how can,
how can I combine this the right way?
And throughout these first few years,
what do you see as something that your
team has done really well at honor?
Um, we execute a lot and
crank out a lot of stuff.
Um, I think one of the things
that we did really well was, um,
not rush the build.
Um,
and also having the realization that
we needed to be completely open minded
because none of us are from health care.
Um,
and so because the team stayed small
and Nimble and we were very sort of
focused,
I think focus for startups is key.
Like most startups die from
suicide and homicide. Um,
and so for us we just had to stay laser
focused. Okay. What are we building? Um,
and because the team,
some of us have worked together before
and we were very picky about hiring,
having really high
bandwidth communication, um,
really excels your timeline to be
able to build something. So, you know,
most home care agencies
tap out at a certain scale,
which is why the industry is very
fragmented. Um, and so within,
call it three years of our inception,
we are probably one of the largest
home care entities in the barrier,
maybe the largest.
Um,
it took us three years to get
there when it usually takes 15.
So it kind of speaks to
combination of like good teamwork,
like the right technology, you know,
sort of cutting edge stuff. Um,
and then really understanding
how to learn from things.
I think one of the downsides of the
industry is that there are so many well
intentioned people but they don't have
the means and the technology to learn and
iterate. And so getting data is really
hard for them. Everything's, you know,
in spiral bound notebooks
and things like that. Um,
and for us we can get a lot of data.
Like we have so much data about how care
works, how do you do matching, you know,
what are the trends?
Like what are we seeing in terms of shift
lengths and days and areas and markets
and pricing and waging what wages.
And so all of that you can kind of
use to learn and improve the service.
When I think the current industry
has a hard time accessing that. So,
and as you were deciding whether to
jump back into doing a startup or not,
what were some factors that
you were considering? Um,
that is just always very personal.
Um,
so obviously I was at the
age where I wanted to have
kids. Um, and so I was like,
well if you really nice just to state
Google cause they have like really good
maternity leave and it's like really
comfortable. Um, and you know,
like I can have like a very routine
schedule. Um, at the same time though,
I think I had it had that,
that need to, to do more. Um,
I think Meebo he wouldn't, maybe it
was great. I mean I had a great time,
but it didn't have the impact that I
think when we got older we really wanted,
um, and uh, startups, average lifespan.
And I say this law is about seven years
to some sort of event or sort of pivot.
Um, and so I was like, wow, I do, I really
want to dedicate another seven years, um,
and have kids while I do that.
And you know, all that stuff. Um,
and so the allure of working
with my cofounders again,
um, it was just really good timing in
terms of like the senior space. Um,
no one had really made a big play
in it before and we were like,
we can really solve this. Um, I,
I use this analogy a lot in
my cofounder does as well,
but a lot of problems that entrepreneurs
run into that are big if you think
about it like an onion is that you
peel back one layer, you're like, oh,
I can solve that. If people are going
to delay your, like I could solve that.
And then at some point you keep peeling,
we hit this hardcore and you're like,
crap,
like I can't solve that.
It's like a regulation or it would take
like 10 years to build or I need to get
like government approval and now it takes
like six years or whatever. Um, but in,
in sort of the home care space,
we kept peeling.
We couldn't find anything that was
super hard because we're like, oh,
we could sell that because I
thought we could sell that.
And that was just really exciting. Um,
and so jumping back in, we're like,
all right,
let's just,
let's just do this because you
basically have to commit 100% or zero,
like you can't have half to do it. Um, and
so, uh, we all kind of said, all right,
let's just buckle up and do it. Um,
have kids with all along the way. Um,
and so,
uh,
this decision to do it was like actually
quite easy one when we can just talk
about that way. Um, and so far I've
seen no have no regrets. So, oh yeah,
that was comprehensive answer,
I think
time to open it up for the
audience. Questions. Hi Sandy. Um,
I have a question about, um, I think
what you're doing is fantastic.
I think you have a great product and
everything you're doing for the senior
community.
Um,
a couple of years ago I went
to the National Association
for the Deaf Conference.
It was in Atlanta and they also
had one in Phoenix as well.
And I met a lot of members from the
deaf community who are aging, um,
specific groups of seniors,
helping people find a place to go.
Do you have any involvement
with the deaf community, uh,
with your product or your services?
Um,
something that would be
accessible for the deaf community?
So specifically,
um,
we don't have anything specifically
targeted towards the death,
but like I said before,
our audience and the client demographic,
it's very heterogeneous. We have people
with all sorts of conditions. Um,
and so we don't say, okay, just because
you have this condition or that condition,
we can't serve you. It's really dependent
on the kind of care the person needs.
And so let's say someone is deaf,
they have a bad hip, uh, they require,
uh,
more lifting and transferring out of bed,
then we would just try to find the right
caregiver to then surface that person.
So,
um,
we do have partnerships with
more disease specific, um,
uh, organization. So the pocket knife,
National Parkinson's foundation, um,
and uh, national, the, um, um,
cancer organizations.
But, uh, in the future,
obviously we'd hope to partner with
more people. But again, like we don't,
there's no like specifically
targeted service for death,
but death to cause your death doesn't
mean you can't help them care. So.
Okay. Here's a question from
the dory. Uh, besides honor,
what our key technological improvements
that you believe have improved elderly
care? What other technological
improvements would you
like to see in the space to
improve the experience for both
the caretaker and the elderly?
Yeah, I think the biggest thing
is probably just access. Um,
there are a lot of devices and market,
a lot of technologies that are, uh,
like I said, really like
specifically targeted for seniors,
but they're taking a very,
um, non granular stance.
So like I said, the bigger buttons,
the big fonts and the senior, like,
have you talked to a lot of older adults?
They don't like things dumbed down
for them. Like they're like, I'm,
I'm perfectly capable of
using it regular device. Um,
so I think there needs to
be a change in the attitude,
I think more than the actual devices.
Um,
because if you sort of rethink
the way you frame technology,
you can like I know plenty of seniors
who use iPhones and android phones and a
very expert manner. Um, and there
are some folks who don't. Um,
and so there I think the,
if you change the way
that you target seniors,
I think that would be a big difference.
Um,
things that I think it had been
really helpful for folks are, um,
you know, more, um,
more educational tools for folks who
help seniors is probably a good step.
So the fact that we have an APP for care
pros is actually like a novel thing for
the industry.
Um,
but it makes them better enabled to
help people who require help. Um,
I would say the, um, one
thing that is a, a lot of the,
um, the physical access things
that you and I take for granted,
like walking upstairs, going
through her door, Romania, lot code,
those kinds of things could probably
be improved as the senior population
increased it, uh, it gets larger.
Um, so basically I think that my,
my biggest thing is not specifics,
but more of the attitude change I think
is probably more important than the
actual,
like physical things are being built.
And related to that,
have you thought about maybe expanding
your sphere of care into sort of
providing support services for the family
members who are maybe like learning
about working or,
uh,
supporting their family members who are
becoming elderly and maybe developing
additional needs that
they didn't have before?
Yeah, so home care, generally speaking,
people don't think about it
until they really need it.
So it don't care is usually
triggered by an acute event,
usually a fall or a met like a, um,
a surgery or something medical. Um,
if we had the a lot earlier,
we could actually then introduce
care and a more lightweight manner.
So then that way the transition
into home care is less jarring.
Um,
in terms of family members,
we do have a lot of family members who
get home care for their spouses or their
parents, um, as respite care.
So they are the primary
caretaker and they live with the,
with with the person
Riverton, uh, receiving care.
But they might need a day off or they
might need three days off every week cause
it's kind of a full time job.
And so the sub supplement with with honor,
we're home care to help with that.
Um, and I think the other, um,
part of it is that, uh, a lot of people
who are in this situation feel very alone.
Um, there aren't like social
networks for people who are giving,
who are receiving home care for their
family members and no one talks about this
like on Facebook or whatever.
Right? It's not like you're saying,
oh my mom got here today. Like
no one talks about it. So, uh,
opening up the conversation,
having more community around that.
It's one of our goals as well. Um,
and also just the transparency.
It's like having the peace of mind
to get home care. Cause it's scary.
It's like you're letting a stranger
into your home and take care of your,
your mom or dad doing very intimate things
like going to the bathroom or getting
out of bed.
Um,
and so the support network I
think needs to be there. Um,
cause almost everybody we talked to,
um,
has a personal story but they don't
never share it because it's just,
it's come up.
It's a very taboo subject.
So I'm hoping it opening to hoping to
open up that that dialogue is one of the
things that we're trying to do,
which is why I think we we frame honor
and a very positive light. A lot of um,
agencies were senior related products
on TV you see or like the help I've
fallen, I can't get up or it's
like very like fear based. Um,
we chose amber as a very bright
color, very positive color. Um,
we talked about it a very positive manner.
We have positive images,
not images that sort of
instill fear or um, you know,
sort of the,
the more scary side of that.
How do you reach new clients and convey
valleys of trust and safety in non tech
cities where people have not heard of
honor and may rely on word of mouth or
local searches?
Yeah. So healthcare
traditionally is a very local,
so word of mouth is extremely
powerful. Um, and you can't just,
when home care market share
by like advertising on,
on Google or Facebook because
that's not how you reach people. Um,
and like I said,
a lot of times home care is triggered by
an acute event and so you're not paying
attention anything in home care or in
the elderly space where the health care
space until something
happens. And then, you know,
our job is to be there when that happens.
So I'm addressing the part where someone
who's not very tech savvy or they don't
really know much about honor.
Um,
the one thing that we have to
portray is that we are human. And so,
um, prior to any home
care, um, set of visits,
we send a fee like a person I cared one
of our care advisors to your home to do
a consultation.
Like they talk you through the plan and
they talk you through what your needs
are. They listen to what you need. Cause
a lot of times just don't, don't know.
It's like, okay, my mom
fell. What do I do? Okay,
you need someone to actually like walk
you through that process. And so, um,
basically instilling trust via a person
is still a great way to do it. Um,
and so that's something that
we do definitely employ. Um,
and then also just being a
knowledge expert. So again,
when you're like emotional and you're
scared and you don't know what you're
doing, you want someone to tell you
it's okay. I've done this before,
I've seen this before.
Like, let me listen to you,
I can help you through this process.
Um, and so that's a very, very, um,
serious thing that we take very seriously
to make sure that when people come
into honor, when people
think about home care, um,
they think about honor and as a
very calming expert voice, um,
it's something we strive,
we strive to sort of propagate.
You mentioned that a lot of the seniors
that solicit care for themselves reach
out to you via phone.
So how do they find you?
Do you also advertise then in traditional
media as well? The yellow pages,
all those? Yeah, so it's been a bit of
a challenge to find out where those,
where those things are. Um, the,
a lot of times, um, like I said,
weren't math is most powerful. So reaching
the influencers within the community.
So like a local pastor, uh, local, um,
senior organization,
um, the, the, um, the,
you know,
discharge nurse at a facility,
it happens near all the community
members. Um, you know, the mayor,
whoever like is sort of an community
influencer. So that's one way to do it.
The other way is just basically to
provide care and then have referrals.
So if someone has a great experience with
us, they will tell their friends. Um,
because generally speaking,
if you were getting care,
you probably know the people were
getting care. Um, and then, you know,
obviously you try to sort of, um,
advertise and sort of the normal channels,
but those are all but less effective.
Just because it can be generally not in
your frame of mind when you need to. Um,
and then the other part is to partner
with other people who deal with seniors.
So we opened up a partner network to work
with existing home care agencies. Um,
we work with, um, system, so
hospitals and facilities, um,
nursing facilities,
discharge facilities to help spread the
word so that they know that honors and
option. Um, and that, you know,
we're differentiated from the rest of
the other agencies around because we have
all these sort of benefits so that even
these traditional organizations are
willing to work with you.
They're not scared of that and
somehow you're going to take over.
We're encompass some of what they're doing
and take this this week. Yeah. So, um,
it's been interesting with that
particular, um, um, partnership network.
Um,
like I said,
a lot of current home healthcare agencies
have a hard time growing cause they're
like, I have do people, it's all in
my head. I don't have technology. I,
it's like really hard for me to,
to like wrangle a care pros and higher
care pros and match care pros. Um,
I get calls at 2:00 AM when a care pro
can't make it and I have to go and like
do the care of myself.
Um,
and so they have to deal with all that
and they don't tend to grow a lot. So, um,
one of our benefits is that we're
really good at the care pro part.
Like a really good recruiting part.
We have technology to help
us do all that stuff and so,
and we can take that burden away
from them. They can actually grow.
And so it's actually a really good
partnership where we both sort of benefit
from that. Um, and we're both,
if both people often st mission,
like we're trying to help people. Um,
but you know, they're good at one part,
we're going another part.
And so if you put it together,
it's actually really good.
Yeah.
So I think this is actually really cool
to see because I think so much of like
the newer like service based economy,
like you look at maybe like Uber
or these other startups, um,
people see them as supplanting an
existing industry and there's a lot of
pushback and conflict between
the traditional industry
and the new tech company.
Um,
whereas here I think it's sort of you're
trying to work together and make it
more of a mutual relationship.
Yeah, definitely. It's, it,
there initially people were a little bit
skeptical that it'll be like, wait, what?
Like here if I'm just like, wait,
what are you guys doing? Um,
but when you kind of explain sort
of like, you know, how we work,
why are we doing this? Like why are
were mission focus, things like that.
Then they start to be like, oh wow.
Like if I really partner with you,
we can really make a better difference,
a bigger difference and help more people.
Um, because a lot of these people who come
into the an inch into the industry are
genuinely there just help people.
Like,
they could make more
money doing other things,
but they really like the work because
they get to interact with clients and talk
to people and help them
through these things. Um,
and so when they find a willing partner
like honor who has all these skills and
tech can like teams that they don't have,
it's actually a pretty exciting. So,
um, it's a new way to innovate on
an existing model, I think, um,
that were like both sides are
pretty excited about it. So,
uh,
another question from the Dory.
What are some key technology or product
decisions that had to be made to ensure
that honor is friendly both to the elderly
users and also to the family members
who are on different panes of technology?
Familiarity.
Yeah. So, uh, like I said before,
we don't require anybody to know anything
about apps or phones or websites to
use honor. So they could
completely do everything by
phone if they want to do. Um,
because we know that's a huge part of our
audience. Uh, at the same time though,
we do want to push the envelope a little
bit and like sort of give folks the
option is using technology to
see the benefits of it. So, um,
all the technology is optional for the,
the care team of a particular,
um, uh, a care recipient.
So if the family member chooses
to use the family hub, they can,
they don't want to,
they don't have to, um,
they want to log into the website and see
all their bills and see the care notes
sentence. You get emails they can, but if
they don't want to, they don't have to.
So we are trying to be very respectful
of the way the current industry works and
how some people just don't want to touch.
It's too complicated to touch tech. Um,
same time though,
if there are folks who really want
to like stick take that leap, um,
we're there with them as well.
Um,
the one thing we do require our care
pros do is care pros have is the APP. Um,
and they actually love it. So we do push
the technology on the workforce, um,
but definitely makes them more effective,
more, um, aware of what's going on. Um,
better enable them to find more
jobs by more work or more money.
So that's sort of our,
our balance. But yeah,
if you don't know anything about tech,
you can just use a rotary phone and
call us every day if you want to do
elderly care by nonfamily members is
common in the u s but in some other
countries like the Ukraine,
it is not culturally accepted,
but there is a huge market for it.
I wonder your thoughts on how to help
make a service like honor be acceptable in
such a culture.
Yeah. Um, we've, we've actually been, uh,
people have reached out
to us from different, uh,
sort of care organizations from
different countries. I'm wondering,
we're going to expand to their country.
Obviously we'd love to do that one day,
but obviously not right now.
Um,
culturally you have to respect
the way that care works.
But I think the trend of more and more
people moving to more urban areas,
um, more more people moving out of
their city that they're born in, um,
tends to sort of consolidate a lot of
the same types of concerns around senior
care. So, you know, um,
if you don't live in the same place as
your parents moving your parents to where
you are, it can be rather expensive,
right? If you live in a more urban area,
it's just real estate. It's
tighter. Houses are smaller, um,
transportation harder,
especially in accessibility.
So if someone has, you know,
a 90 year old mother who
can't do stairs very well,
but you live on the sixth
floor of an apartment,
that's a really difficult thing to
have to deal with. And so a lot of the,
even though culturally people
may have different expectations,
I think a lot of the trends are
moving towards the same direction.
And so I think in the future we have
to just find that balance of obviously
respecting the current,
the current tradition,
but also pushing folks to understand
the reality of what's happening.
Um, and then, you know, kind
of just to see, you know,
maybe all the caregivers in the particular
country are very different from the
ones in the u s maybe they're doing
it, they're, maybe they're not. Um,
if we can introduce, introduce, um, a way
of doing things, maybe that, you know,
spurs a new kind of trend or
movement, but, um, any of the day,
I think generally speaking,
a lot of countries are kind of
migrating towards the same problems.
Words matter in the space that
you're working in right now.
How does your messaging change between
the patient versus the family member or
caregiver to communicate
your value proposition?
What has resonated the most and the least?
Who's,
who's usually making
the purchase decision?
So generally speaking,
it's usually the adult child that's making
the purchase decision. Um, uh, and so,
um,
it's an interesting conversation.
So the most effective communicator
is usually the family member to the,
um, senior. Um, but sometimes
it's not. So we do have, um,
care Syrians who are resistant to care.
So they like,
they don't want someone in their home,
they don't want to carry it,
that they need it.
Um,
and sometimes they would rather talk to
us then their family member because they
don't want to expose some their needs to
the family member because what happens
is it when you expose that
you are exposing a lack of
control and that's really
scary.
And so a lot of times we'll have this
like interesting dynamic where they don't
want it like a person person getting care
doesn't want to tell the family member
all that happened.
But they're willing to tell the care
pro because you care if I was helping.
So again, it's all dependent
on the sort of situation. Um,
for the most part we do do a lot
of communication through the um,
family member who's,
who was the one responsible for the
care or the Dillinger relationship. Um,
but a lot of times when the Care
Sabine is the actual account owner,
then we directly communicate with them.
Can you tell us about how
you train your care pros?
Is it in person training or mostly online?
So most of it right now is in person.
Um,
it's usually most effective cause a lot
of it's sort of like physical stuff that
we're teaching. Um, we loved, we are
hoping to expand to more online things.
But um, for now a lot of it is
physical in the office, on the job.
Um, and also through, um,
through the APP or like sort of
phone or text communication. We do,
we've talked to our care.
It was a lot so that they're in constant
communication with us telling us what
they need to do.
And then how many families
are you currently helping?
So that's not a number we'd generally
expose. Um, but we just, we are,
our sort of canned answer to that is
that we serve the entire bay area,
La, Dallas, fort worth and Albuquerque
when we start New Mexico, Albuquerque,
New Mexico. So it kind of gives you a
general idea of sort of the market sizes,
but we don't actually suppose
the actual number. So,
and then related to the idea of expanding
potentially to areas where it's not
culturally,
um,
common for non family members
to take care of the elderly.
How do you think about not just
expanding into those areas but maybe like
creating materials to help people in
those areas who maybe don't necessarily
interface with your business directly,
but maybe you just provide resources?
Yeah, so that was, uh,
that goes back to the point where just
being a knowledge expert is actually
really helpful. And so I'm not just
having an online presence, but you know,
going and getting into the communities,
it's actually a really,
really positive thing.
So when you go to a senior center
or you go to like a local event,
um, you can just be there and then be a
trusted, like they'd be a familiar face.
So then when people have
questions, they're like, oh,
you should talk to this person. They kind
of have an, I have a better idea of how,
like, how, you know,
the elderly space works.
Then you start to sort of like in
bed yourself better. And so, um,
part of the, the um, way to, um,
get better word of mouth is just sort
of taking advantage of the fact that
health care and home care is very local.
And so you have to respect that.
You can't just be like,
I'm this giant national entity.
I'm just going to go and spread ads
everywhere. Like that doesn't work.
Like you have to really go in and um,
participate and talk to
people and actually like be
in the community to really
make a dent. So that's generally
the tack that will probably,
so what's the pricing structure look like
in this industry and where do you find
and where does honor place itself?
Yeah, so pricing generally is by um,
shift length. So it's like an hourly early
because the care pros get paid hourly.
Um,
we're kind of like right smack in the
middle with most of the industry in terms
of our pricing. Um, certain areas are a
little harder to serve. So, for example,
if you are a care pro making minimum
wage or a little bit above, you know,
a $6 bridge toll from the East Bay to
the peninsula is a lot of money for you.
And so it's much harder for you to get
from East Bay to let's say Palo Alto and
so in certain harder to reach
areas. So Palo Alto, you know,
as parts of San Francisco prices can be
a little higher because we have to be
able to pay the care pro more. Um, that's
generally more of a common trend with,
with uh, home care.
But generally speaking,
we're kind of like very
much market prices. Um,
and our hope is that because we can
take a lot of the manual work out of the
process, um, we can, you know, maybe
at some point charge a little less,
pay a little more and it'll take that,
those gains because we have a little more
efficiency within our system since we
are using the employee model.
Does that mean that care pros have to
work a certain number of hours or certain
shifts during, um, within with W2's? Uh,
you don't have to like
enforce a certain hour.
We have some folks who use us who work
with us on more of a part time basis or
they just pick up shifts in the evening
or on the weekends because they have
another job.
Um,
we have other folks who use us as their
primary Gig and so we are their primary
employer and they take most of the work
from us. It's very fuck. Like it's,
it's more flexible and I think then people
kind of think about when think about
employee model,
but um,
like we do realize that care pros have
a lot of restrictions in terms of what
they can and can't do. You know,
folks at Google generally don't have,
when you have trouble with your car
it's like, oh, it's really annoying.
But when your car is the only thing
that is really providing your work,
uh, conduit, um, it's, it's a lot harder.
And so we just to make sure that we're
respectful of that and we provide enough
sort of options of types of work for
our care pros. And I'm wrapping up.
I have one question about any specific
technology or product that you're excited
about in the near future?
I would say the just for more than one.
Yeah,
I guess I just related to
honor, um, there's much more
intention now to seniors.
I think that's awesome. Um, before honor,
there was like no funding in the
senior space. Um, and now we have,
um, you know, companies like really,
really focusing on how
to cater to seniors. Um,
and not just like building
devices or technology,
but sort of really thinking about
it from a offerings perspective.
Cause just cause the baby boomers and
senior population is just going to explode
in the next 10 years or 10 to two,
10 to 20 years. So I would say like,
and then maybe nothing specific,
but anything really,
like anybody really investing
in a, uh, not just seniors,
but demographics of audiences that
are not traditionally invested in,
I think is awesome. And that's what
I'm really excited about. Great.
Thank you so much and thank you for
coming today. Thanks for having me.
Thank you everyone for coming here.